colors are easy right there one of the
first things you learn as a kid red
orange yellow green blue purple white
black gray brown pink and then when you
learn otherwise we'll just all you have
to do is learn the new words for the
same colors except it's not actually the
way it works that English color system
with its nicely defined names doesn't
map onto every other language quick
heads up I am massively simplifying here
check the references if you want to know
more details
the most common difference or at least
the most commonly studied difference is
whether blue and green are different
colors or different shades of the same
color one which English linguists refer
to as screw Vietnamese for example uses
the same basic word or lexeme for blue
and green they can literally be
translated as leaf group or ocean group
does that seem weird
it shouldn't that's just a simple change
in where you draw a line on the wheel of
hues the ancient Greeks on the other
hand classified colors not by hue but by
lightness so they had one Lexie one main
word for dark blue green and brown and
one word for light blues Gray's greens
colors like that English uses one word
blue for two very different colors but
in Russian there are two different words
for what we'd call dark blue and light
blue and that really shouldn't seem
strange to English speakers because
that's exactly what we do with dark red
and light red or as we call it pink in
1969 red berlin and paul k released a
book that claimed to track the evolution
of color in languages according to
berlin k languages start out with just
words for dark cool colors and light
warm colors then gain a word for red
then green and yellow and blue brown and
the rest of what english refers to as
the spectrum there is some debate about
how accurate that is and by some debate
I mean this is a really controversial
subject in linguistics and has been for
decades I'm skimming over the very
basics here but there are reams of
research going into some very deep
claims that are not vaguely qualified to
discuss lots of linguists with very
impressive degrees have very strong and
very different opinions on this because
something as apparently simple as color
differences highlight just how tricky
translation and cross-cultural
communication can be but the debate goes
a level deeper than that
it's about whether the words we know and
the languages we learn
influence the way we interpret the world
or whether they just reflect our
existing interpretations and the answer
is I don't know no one does really not
yet
the answer is probably somewhere in
between because language is complicated
people are complicated and sometimes
things really aren't just black and
white I really need to write better puns